Hallo. Das Podcast UFO. Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Radio Hour. Mit mir Stefan Tietze und dir, Florantin Will. Hallo Stefan, ich freue mich sehr, heute dabei sein zu dürfen. Und natürlich vielen Dank für unseren Türöffner, für unseren kleinen Dietrich, der uns heute herrlich in diese Folge hinein willkommen geheissen hat. Vielen Dank an Tim für das Intro.
Dankeschön, dass ihr immer so tolle Intros schickt.
Es freut uns immer sehr.
Aber wir freuen uns natürlich heute auch einen der wahrscheinlich furchtlosen Tabubrecher Deutschlands hier am Tisch sitzen.
War aber Stefan Tietz ist hier.
Hallo.
Ist das das Kulturradio, in dem ich hier bin?
Völlig richtig, genau.
Ja.
Jetzt hört man an dem ASMR-Charakter. Sternenstunde Philosophie, da würde ich gerne mal, da sehe ich mich.
Ja, wirklich? Aber du würdest die ganze Zeit nur schlürfen. Und du würdest immer so warten, bis du eine dünne Frage gestellt bekommst, und dann würdest du erst mal schlürfen. Genau, ich würde eine Frage, also wenn eine Frage kommt, stell mal eine Frage. Ja, Herr Tietze, wie sehen Sie denn in aktuellen sozioökonomischen Situationen die Frage, die sich weiterhin im Spannungsfeld
zuspitzt zwischen einerseits der Klassenfrage auf der einen, andererseits natürlich die
vielen Ismen, mit denen wir immer noch leider zu kämpfen haben. Wie sehen Sie da Perspektiven
aus dieser Situation heraus?
Ja, das Spannende ist, da habe ich neulich auch noch mal Hegel gelesen. Vielen Dank. Und man hofft dann ein bisschen, dass die Frage, die man nicht verstanden hat, vergessen wurde. Bisschen problematisch, wenn man halt nur zu zweit im Raum ist. Und diese Frage, wie da ein Elefant auch noch im Raum schwebt. Die kriegst du nicht raus. Da hilft kein Lüften, da hilft kein Raumspray. Manche Fragen kriegt man nicht aus dem Raume. Wir haben gerade uns oft ganz doll gestritten, ob das, wenn ein Kind in den Brunnen gefallen ist, ist ein bisschen wie, ich muss die Kuh vom Eis holen. Das sind die paar Sprichwörter, die ich mag, habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt. Aber das Kind ist bereits in den Brunnen gefallen, dann ist es aber finito, ne? Das war es dann. Genau, man darf dann auch das Kind nicht mehr aus dem Brunnen holen. Nee, aber ich glaube, es geht auch nicht. Also das Unglück ist bereits geschehen, darum geht es. Und wenn es noch den Hauch einer Chance gibt, dass man die Situation retten kann, dann ist das Kind nicht in den Brunnen gefallen.
Da hat man das nicht zu sagen.
Wir stellen uns eine Welt ohne Seile vor, in der wirklich, wenn das Kind in den Brunnen gefallen ist, dann ist auch wirklich ganz nichts am Machen.
Mir gefällt diese Ruhe, in der das gesagt wird.
Nee, das Kind ist bereits in den Brunnen gefallen.
So als wäre das ein Problem, was in diesem Dorf, ich stelle mir so ein Mittelalter Dorf vor, die schon alles gesehen haben.
Und jetzt ist ein Kind in den Brunnen gefallen und das ist jetzt auch nicht mehr. Das ist ja auch eher wie ein Tropfen auf einem Eisenstein. Aber könnte man nicht rein theoretisch ganz viel Wasser in den Brunnen kippen, damit das Kind auch oben schwimmt? Ja, aber was es meint, ist es bereits verstorben. Also es ist glaube ich, das Kind ist bereits in den Brunnen gefallen, heißt es bereits tot, das war's. Und jetzt post mortem kannst du dann Dinge machen. Oder heißt es auch, dass es Grundwasser vergiftet? Nein. Nee, das glaube ich nicht. Jetzt will ich ein bisschen zu viel. So schlimm ist es dann doch nicht. Also alles andere ist noch rettbar. Da ist dann Hopf und Malz noch nicht verloren. Also das musst du dann auch gucken. Dieses Dorf hat auch die Kirche im Dorf gelassen, finde ich. Wir lernen so viel hier. Wahnsinn. Ich habe zum Beispiel, glaube ich, heute Morgen erst gelernt, dass Will I Am ja William heißt. Wahnsinn. Ich glaube, wir fangen jetzt erst an, die Black-Eyed-Peace wirklich zu verstehen nach all der Zeit.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt wirklich diese Phase, wo noch mal viel Sekundärliteratur auf den Markt kommt, wo man sich noch mal viel an sich anguckt, wo man all diese Dinge noch mal aufarbeiten kann.
Ich glaube, während der Zeit konnte kaum jemand diesen Tornado, diesen Wirbelsturm überhaupt greifen.
Sind die Black-Eyed-Peace nicht wahnsinnig ... überschätzt? Oh. Ja, Stefan hat in seinem sechzigbändigen Klett-Cotta-Ausgabe Wie überschätzt sind die Black-Eyed-Peace, Band eins bis sechzehn, dargelegt, dass vielleicht Let's Get It Started nicht der Jahrhunderthit war, den man damals gedacht hatte.
Let's get it started finde ich eigentlich brillant, aber ab da ging es so ein bisschen, da ist irgendwann das Kind dann in den Brunnen gefallen, weil da kamen dann irgendwann so Sachen, I got a feeling und so, klar sind das, sind quasi so Schlagerpop, das will man ja, das ist ja jetzt, dem kann man ja keine musikalische Komplexität zuschreiben mehr. Das ist ja einfach nur noch Unsinn ein bisschen auch. Würdest du dann sagen, Fergie ist höher anzurechnen als Black Eyed Peas insgesamt? Ja, Fergie muss man nochmal ganz... Fergie muss man nochmal völlig freudig. Ich will dich bitten, dass wir da nochmal in Ruhe drüber reden. Okay, nee, dann machen wir nach meiner Sonderfolge auch. Entschuldigung, das tut mir auch leid, dass es sich nicht vorbereitet. Das passt jetzt hier nicht hin, aber klar, Fergie muss man als ganz eigenes Konstrukt nochmal nebenbei betrachten, die ja für sich viel besser funktioniert. Okay, dann lass uns doch kurz direkt die Top drei Black Eyed Peas machen. Will I Am auf Platz eins, auf der drei, scheiße, Will I Am auf der drei. Okay, Platz zwei, der andere Typ? Ja, the other guy. Und Platz eins Fergie. Und Platz eins ist Fergie, klar. Wir waren uns selten so einig. Sind die zu dritt? Flag, I'd und Peace? Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Ich fand die Musikvideos immer verwirrend, weil die haben sich immer so stark bewegt und ich konnte die Nieder mal richtig durchzählen. Die sind nämlich zu viert. Fergie, Will I da ab apple da apple da ab naja ja da musst du irgendwann raus da muss du irgendwann raus was für die du willst ja auch nicht immer alles durch vierteilen so ich meine was die alles an geld bekommen haben müssen dafür dass sie in den weltraum geschossen wurden da müssen ja Millionen geflossen sein wer an wen aber ehrlich gesagt das ist ein Szenariozenario, wo ich mir auch vorstellen kann, dass die Black Eyed Peas
wahnsinnig viel Geld ausgegeben haben. Ach so, das kann auch sein, ja.
Da wurde so eine Raumsonde in den Weltraum geschossen,
damit in sechs Millionen Jahren noch die
Überreste unserer Kultur zu finden sind.
Und da hat man sich entschieden.
I got a feeling!
Dass man das dann auch findet als Überreste unserer Kultur. Ja, und die ganzen Aliens so, jees, macht das au. Diese Wesen haben grosse Schmerzen, wir müssen ihn retten. Und da wurde Black Eyed Peas darauf graviert. Und da muss viel Geld geflossen sein. Ich habe letztens eine Doku gesehen über archäologische Rätsel. Also Dinge, die offen bleiben. Wo man einfach nicht weiß, was das soll. Und da gab es ein, also einmal gab es zum Beispiel so einen uralten Stein mit einer Steckdose drin. Und dann konnte er halt datieren, dass dieser Stein halt irgendwie so eine, ich glaube, es ist so ein bearbeitetes Stein, ein Ziegelstein, irgendwie halt tausende Jahre alt. Ach so, ich sage nur 1981. Wirklich, also wir reden von Asyrer bis Desyrer oder so. Und da ist halt einfach eine Steckdose drin. Und da der Typ, der diesen Stein gefunden hat in seinem Vorgarten, Elektrikermeister ist, haben damals schon Leute gesagt, nee, du verarscht uns. Und der hat gesagt, nein, testet das. Und die haben selbst in der Steckdose, meinten sie, es sei ein unidentifizierbares Material, aus dem diese Steckdose selber ist. Heißt du auch für eine Steckdose sozusagen Stein? Also es ist auch keine Steckdose, es ist ein Stecker. Also es sind so drei Metallspiesse, die da aus dem Stein einfach rausgucken. Ah, ah ja. Und das ist einfach Mysterium. Meine Frage war, hat jemand mal versucht, den Stein einfach anzustecken in eine Steckdose?
Ob der da leuchtet oder was passiert? Ja genau, das habe ich auch vorgestellt. Geleuchtet auf den ganzen Singen oder sowas. Aber was ist denn da, also drei Stecker. Und nach diesem US-Steckdosen-Prinzip? Ja, ich glaube in England oder so. Oder hat man auch so einen Erdungsstecker oder so. In der EU-Steckdose wird es aber nicht reinpassen. Nee, die Asyre waren nicht in der EU, Stefan. Das ist Quatsch jetzt. Also da musst du jetzt zumindest ein bisschen das Sohn-Frachwissen mitbringen. Okay, aber was ist nicht identifizierbar? Welches Material? Das Material, aus dem dieser Stecker ist. Wie ist es nicht identifizierbar? Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es auch nicht. Das war ein neunminütiges YouTube-Video. Ich habe jetzt nicht alle Daten da,
aber das ist einfach noch offen.
Aber ich glaube, das ist ein Fall, mit dem sich einfach niemand ernsthaft beschäftigt, weil jeder weiß, ja, das ist halt befähigt so. Was ich so nervig langweilig finde, ehrlich gesagt, ist, dass wenn Meteoriten auf die Erde fallen, die einfach aus Eisen sind. Ja. Eisen. Warum nicht Kryptonit? Warum nicht irgendwas Cooles? Eisen. Leute, das reist Jahre, Milliarden durchs Weltall, um dann irgendwann, die Chance ist unsagbar gering, auf unserem kleinen Planetchen hier zu landen, der durch Zufall auch noch an dem Ort ist, wo es dann da ist. Es geht ja nicht nur um die Umlaufbahn, sondern du musst ja dann auch genau drauf prallen, wenn wir hier dann sind. Wie viel Prozent aller Elemente haben wir hier auf der Erde? Haben wir alles? Nee, die meisten sind ja gar nicht fest. Ich glaube, nicht viele sind fest. Ich glaube, es sind nur so 30 feste Elemente oder so gibt es. Nagelt mich nicht drauf fest. Nagelt mich bitte nicht drauf fest. Die Leute werden nicht drauf fest nagelt. Ich würde sagen, 14 bis 30 feste Elemente gibt es ja überhaupt nur. Allein können jaünstlich hergestellt werden, hier auf unserem Planetchen. Du bist immer so defensiv, wenn du Sachen erklärst, als ob wirklich in deinem Nacken immer jemand schon die Tastatur auspackt und sofort schreibt. Nimm dir erstmal ein bisschen Raum. Du hast jetzt erstmal bis zum Ende der Folge Zeit, wo dir niemand widerspricht. Schlechte Erfahrungen. Ich werde dir nicht widersprechen. Ne, ganz ehrlich, wir haben schon viel Quatsch behauptet und klar gab es Backlashes, aber die kriegt ihr ja auch nicht mit. Also es ist ja auch nicht so schlimm. Seit wir es Reddit haben schon, die rotten sich langsam zusammen. Die rotten sich zusammen. Aber also, falls ihr wisst, was mit dem Stecker los ist, schreibt uns gerne. Und dann eine Sache, die ich auch noch toll fand, archäologisches Mysterium, und zwar gab es eine Kultur, von der es ab einem gewissen Zeitpunkt gar keine Spuren mehr gab. Die haben ihr Ding gemacht und die hatten eine eigene Kultur. Irgendwo in Asien. Und die haben ihre eigene Kultur gemacht und die hatten so grosse Steinköpfe, die aber so ein bisschen anders als menschlich aussahen irgendwie. Mit so grösseren Augen und so. Und die haben die dann auch vergraben und so. Und da gibt es einfach ab einem gewissen punkt sind die einfach weg und es gibt auch keine beschreibung wie die irgendwie erobert wurden oder wie die sich aufgespalten haben nichts die sind einfach ab einem gewissen punkt weg und dann gibt es verschiedene theorien und verschiedene archäologen und historiker haben sich überlegt was könnte passieren sein einer sagt erdbeben was finde ich ein bisschen faul ist weil man kann alles mit erdbeben erklären erklären, das ist jetzt keine gute Kunst. Und die zweite Theorie, die hat mir am besten gefallen, ist... Aber ganz kurz, das ist nicht so gut, um Wissenschaft zu bewerten, langweilig, weil das könnte alles erklären. Ja, nee, das ist ja... Also wenn du, weil, ne, auch hier geht Ockhams Rasiermesser, die leichteste Erklärung ist oft die richtige, und wenn du sagst, das ist jetzt so langweilig... Du brauchst auch keine Wissenschaft, wenn du sagst, warum sind die Dinos ausgestorben? Ja, Erdbeben. Warum gibt es keine Säbelzahntiger mehr? Ja, Erdbeben. So kann ich ja auch alles sagen. Meine Vorstellung, meine Nebenvorstellung von Erdbeben ist immer diese neuropäische Vorstellung von Erdbeben. So, es wackelt leicht. Und dann stelle ich mir immer alle Dinos vor, die dann so leicht auf einer Massageplatte stehen, fett wabertert und dann keben alle um tot. Ja, wie auch so wie beim Flughafen, auf diesen Bändern, wo man dann kurz mal stehen bleibt und dann geht's aber auch wieder. Genau, manche Dinge kann ich mir nicht vorstellen im Kopf. Nee, kann ich auch nicht. Also ich habe Respekt davor und ich finde es schlimm, dass viele Menschen an Erdbeben sterben, aber in meinem Kopf kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen. Ich stelle mir immer vor ... Aber mein Problem ist, ich stelle mir eine ganz glatte Ebene vor, wie so eine Wüste. Und da stehen dann vereinzelt Dinos hin, wie von mir so als Kind hingestellt. Und da ist aber sonst auch nichts. Und das Schaffelt dann so hin und her. Das Schaffelt hin und her, und da ist es für mich unerklärlich wieder, weil ich sterbe. Ich glaube, das Nächste, wie ich jemals an einem Erdbeben war, ist, wenn du auf einem Trampolin liegst, auf dem noch jemand springt. Und du sagst, aber hey, stopp, stopp, stopp, ich komme nicht mehr hoch. Aber halt, halt, halt. Und deine Brüder springen auf dem Trampolin und du liegst am Boden und kommst nicht mehr hoch. Und dann dachte ich mir, das ist schon furchteinflößend. Und so geht es jetzt aber allen gleichzeitig. Dass alle so haben, hey, hey, hey, lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz. Dass alle so auf dem Boden liegen und nicht mehr hochkommen. Und das eine gesamte Bevölkerung. Aber es gab wie gesagt noch eine zweite Theorie, die mir gut gefallen hat neben Erdbeben, und für die bin ich natürlich auch, weil ich immer Anti-Erdbeben bin, das ist in der Fachpresse mittlerweile bekannt. Und die zweite Theorie, warum man ab einem gewissen Punkt nichts mehr von dieser Kultur gehört hat, war, dass sie sich einfach aufgelöst haben, dass die einfach keinen Bock mehr hatten auf ihre Kultur und einfach gemeinschaftlich beschlossen haben, wir hören auf, wir machen den Laden zu. Also wenn eine Firma bankrott geht, dass die einfach sagen, das ist doch scheiße, oder mit diesen Köpfen und unsere Feste sind lame, lass uns hier einfach, oder habt ihr noch Bock, jetzt mal ernsthaft, habt ihr noch Bock? Nee, wenn wir abends in unserer Höhle sitzen und, weil wir haben lame, wir haben dieses Spiel, was wir die ganze Zeit spielen, wer am längsten nicht sagt, gewinnt, da spielen wir ja jeden Abend in unserer Höhle. Wir haben ein Instrument, so eine komische Flöte, die nervt, wir haben zwei Lieder. Und immer wenn wir abends in unserer Höhle sitzen und nebenan die Kultur, hört ihr die Musik, die da abgeht. I got a feeling, the tonight's gonna be big. Und dann geht die Höhlen-Tour auf. Ne, Leute, lasst uns, also ganz kurz, lasst uns kurz eine Abstimmung machen. Mahantuch, wer hat Bock noch weiterzumachen? Mahantuch? Meinst du mich? Mahantuch? Unsere Anführerin? Mahantuch? Was? Mahantuch, kannst du mal die Liste rausholen und wir zählen, wer noch Bock hat? Also, Mahala, Handuch, wer noch Bock hat? Wer noch Bock hat. Ist auch da. Wer noch Bock hat, ist auch da. Und es meldet sich einfach eine Person. Ich fand es schon okay so. Ich habe es gemocht. Dann lass uns hier Schluss machen, oder? Ja, gut. Dann lass uns alle Köpfe, die wir noch haben, eingraben. Und ja, war eine geile Zeit. Haut rein. Ich glaube auch, dass sie dann beschliessen, sich so aufzulösen, dass auch nichts mehr zu finden ist. Also es klingt auch so, als würden sie sich schämen, rückblickend für das. Lass uns, egal, also wir gehen jetzt in alle möglichen anderen Himmelsrichtungen, andere Kulturen und lass uns einfach nicht drüber reden. Also lass uns einfach so die Lieder vergessen, wir vergraben alles. Wenn jemand fragt, wo wer kommst du denn, sagen wir Westen.
Ja, so aus den Dünen, aus den Steppen oder sowas.
Und auch wenn wir uns irgendwie zufällig noch treffen in der Fußgängerzone, wir haben uns nie gesehen.
Ist das klar, haben das alle verstanden.
Wir haben uns nie gesehen.
Und dann würde ich sagen, ja, viel Glück und viel Segen auf allen. Nein, nie wieder, nie wieder, nie wieder. Ciao, macht's gut, ciao. Wirft so Dreck auf den Boden und verschwindet im Rauch. Aber das ist merkwürdig, weil das kann man aus unserer Perspektive gar nicht verstehen, weil die ja quasi 99 Prozent aller Kulturen kämpfen ja rein ums Überleben, expandieren, ihre Kultur auf andere zu übertragen. Eben, außer die. Die machen selber Schluss. Es gibt viele Gründe, warum eine Kultur sterben kann. Irgendwie wird assimiliert, Krieg, Tod, alle tot oder halt, und das müssen wir jetzt leider immer aufführen in unserem Buch, wenn Leute einfach keinen Bock mehr haben. Einfach keinen Bock mehr. Auflösung, einfach sagen das eine gute Idee, weil es ist ja immer so, es gibt ja manche Länder auch heutzutage, wo man sagt, hör doch auf, lass doch sein, das bringt doch nichts mehr. So diese ganz kleinen Länder oder so, Luxemburg oder so, kann man da nicht sagen, oh Leute, komm, kein Bock mehr. Ich kriege jetzt aus irgendeinem Grund, hat der Instagram-Algorithmus beschlossen, dass ich Bock auf luxemburgischen Content hab. Und ich schau mir das in Faszination an, weil ich meine... Ist ja auch nicht viel. Weil ich meine, sorry, ist ja nicht viel. Das hast du in zwei Wochen weggeguckt. Und dann hast du es auch. Und dann hast du es abgeschlossen. Aber erst guckst du das an und denkst dir, okay, das ist ja undeutliches Deutsch. Und dann hörst du aktiv zu und dann denkst du, ach, das ist eine andere Sprache.
Und dann hat der Algorithmus aber schon gemerkt, oh, du schaust das interessiert und lange an, du hast dich nach vorne gelehnt.
Mehr davon bitte. Das war aber nur aus Verwirrung heraus.
Und deswegen kriege ich immer mehr, ich komme aus diesem Schneeball nicht mehr raus.
Ich glaube aber auch, dass Algorithmen Verwirrung verstehen.
Aber Algorithmen finden das auch, also du bist ja jetzt trotzdem drin, weißt du, und der Algorithmus ist ja trotzdem recht behalten. Ich glaube, der checkt, ob es ein aufrichtiges Nach vorne lehnen ist oder nicht. Wie diese Experimente, ich habe von meinem Hund geweint, wie der Hund reagiert und so. Und der Hund denkt immer, Jesus, weil Hunde checken das ja auch, wenn jemand dann nicht richtig schlägt oder weint. Bei diesen Reaction-Videos denke ich mir immer. Der Hund ist einfach nur verwirrt. Und das ist genau so. Der Algorithmus weiss das genau, wie du das guckst. Aber du guckst es ja. Also hat er recht. Aber ich frage mich, ob die nicht auch so Leute in die Richtung drängen wollen. Das kannst du ja auch machen, weil wenn du jetzt Luxemburg bist und du sagst, wir brauchen mehr Leute, wir brauchen mehr Platz, wir brauchen irgendwas und dann sagst du, ja gib doch mal hier ein paar Millionen an TikTok und Instagram, lass doch mal unseren Content streuen und dräng die Leute mal so in Richtung Luxemburg so. Das gibt es ja bestimmt auch, dass die dich da so in die Richtung drängen, dass da irgendjemand im Hintergrund sagt, so jetzt muss gepusht werden. Ja, ausgibt. Kann gut sein. Ich dachte gerade, das sage ich noch bei der Kultur, es ist wie Bands. Und Bands sind so anders als Kulturen, weil Bands lösen sich die ganze Zeit auf, weil sie keinen Bock mehr haben. Das stimmt. Entweder aufeinander oder auf die Songs oder weil andere Sachen dazwischen kommen. Da ist es andersrum, da ist da nur noch ein Prozent aufgrund von Erdbeben oder Krankheit oder so. Ja, oder Krieg. Also es gibt jetzt, selbst War of the Bands endet selten tödlich. Das stimmt, ja. Häufig gibt es Friedensbeschlüsse und Waffenstillstände am Ende eines War of the Bands. Also es ist nicht so, dass die sich dann jetzt gegenseitig irgendwie, und die wollen auch nicht, du willst nicht eine andere Band einnehmen, Nein. um dann noch einen Schleichzeuger, einen Bassisten und einen Sänger zu haben. Du hast jetzt nicht genug Platz im Tourbus. Eben. Wir haben ja jetzt schon Probleme, wenn Melly mitkommt. Ich weiß eh nicht, warum deine Freundin ständig mitkommen muss. Wieso? Die singt doch super. Ja, aber die ist nicht Teil der Band. Ja, aber ich weiß, wir brauchen jemanden, der macht Merch und so, aber das können wir auch vor Ort, können wir das auch gucken. Die muss doch jetzt nicht ständig mitkommen. Wir waren einfach, als Band haben wir angefangen und jetzt, ich meine, sorry. Was hast du jetzt gegen sie? Ich habe vorher bei WhatsApp gefragt, ob das okay ist, wenn sie mitkommt. Ja, und ich habe mit dem Shrug-Emoji geantwortet, das war eher nein eigentlich. Habe ich nicht so verstanden. Wie hast du es denn verstanden, wenn du sagst, soll sie mitkommen und ich ... Ja, na klar, ich habe nichts gegen einen zu wenden.
Das ist sehr schwach, das ist für dich.
Ja, was soll ich dazu sagen?
Klar, Chlor, sowas, Chlor.
Alle anderen waren dafür.
Das war kein Chlor.
Chlor, alle anderen waren auch dafür.
Ja, aber dann, wir spielen nicht mehr ihren Song, okay?
Mellys Song?
Wir spielen nicht mehr ihren Song.
Mellys Song? Nein, wir spielen nicht Caramelly Song. Caramell Melly, das spielen wir nicht mehr. Wir sind eine Death Metal Band. Dann war es das jetzt hier. Wir lösen es auf. Was? Wir vergraben unsere Statuen. Wir vergraben unsere Stative. Und wir vergessen unsere Songs. Jetzt vergessen alle. Dann machst du und Melly dein eigenes Ding. Dann wollen wir mal sehen, wer hier auf dem Mond landet mit seiner goldenen Platine. Ja, alles klar. Mit Melly's Song. Ciao. Aber ehrlich gesagt, weil da ist nicht so, dass es durch Krieg oder so verloren geht, sondern das sind wirklich hundertprozentig, lösen sich Bands einfach auf. Ja. Und das ist auch gut so, weil sonst gibt es zu viele. Das stimmt. Stell dir mal vor, die würden sich nie auflösen. Wir hätten ein echtes Problem, wenn die sich nicht auflösen würden. Niemand würde arbeiten, alle würden nur so einen Quatsch machen. Stell dir vor, wir hätten immer noch Tic-Tac-Toe rumliegen irgendwo. Ja, also brauchen wir nicht. So irgendwo auf irgendeinem Regal und irgendwie immer bei Festivals oder so. Und du denkst dir, Leute, da müssen auch Leute nachkommen. Ja, viel zu voll. Weil die haben jetzt schon sehr viele Bands. Du darfst jeder nur noch ein Lied spielen oder nur noch einen Akkord oder so, wenn man sonst gar nicht alle durchkriegt. Nee, genau. Und deswegen ist es so eine gesunde Auflösung von Bands immer. Das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Platz machen. Macht auch mal Platz für andere. Ich habe seit Tagen den größten Knoten im Kopf und es ist wie das leidige Thema Evolution. Und ich möchte dir diese Frage jetzt stellen. Okay. So. Survival of the fittest. Prämisse. Grosses Axiom. Können wir nicht verändern. Also.
Warum bin ich so schwach dann? Und der Mensch ist wahnsinnig intelligent. Und das gibt ihm ja seine Anfassungsfähigkeit.
Also, immer hat sich das Stammhirn des Menschen vergrössert, vergrössert, vergrössert. Dadurch wurde er immer intelligenter und dadurch hat er sich so durchgesetzt. Warum werden nicht alle Tiere die ganze Zeit intelligenter? Warum wachsen nicht von allen Tieren die ganze Zeit die Stammhirne? Weil das ja eh der beste Weg ist, um sich anzupassen. Klar kann Kolibri einen langen Schnabel bekommen, um besser in diese Blüten reinzupiksen, aber der intelligentere Kolibri ja auch. Der intelligente Kolibri findet ja auch andere Wege, um zu überleben, sich fortzupflanzen.
Also warum werden nicht von allen Tieren die ganze Zeit alle Gehirne grösser? Sind wir, es ist ein Freak-Accident? Naja, deine Prämisse ist ja, dass du sagst, der Mensch ist besser angepasst als die Nacktschnecke. Aber das würde ich ja gar nicht sagen. Die Nacktschnecke ist genauso gut an ihre Umwelt angepasst wie der Mensch. Vielleicht sogar besser. Also warum sagst du denn, der Mensch ist jetzt besser an seine Umwelt angepasst oder hat evolutionär gesehen einen besseren Stand als alle anderen Tiere? Weil wir auf den Mond fliegen können, ist es das wieder? Ja, es ist ein bisschen, weil wir auf den Mond fliegen können. Nee, weil wir natürlich uns, man kann sagen, durchgesetzt haben als Spezies Nummer eins. Ja, aber die Amöbe hat sich auch durchgesetzt. Die ist auch noch da. Und vor allem die war auch schon seit Milliarden Jahren da. Das stimmt schon. Und die will ich jetzt auch, also sowas will ich eigentlich auch ausklammern. Bei mir geht es eher so um, sagen wir mal, Schimpansen oder Lemuren. Primär die beiden. Ich frage zwei Freunde. Könnten die nicht ein bisschen schlauer werden? Die fragen, ob die nicht ein bisschen schlauer sein können. Ja. Dann gib mir mal die Nummer und dann gucke ich mal, was man da machen kann. Jetzt so ad hoc weiss ich aber. Jeffrey und Lenny. Aber ich glaube, du findest aber auch unter Menschenfreunde, Stefan, glaube ich. Ich glaube, das ist für dich die bessere Anpassungsmöglichkeit. Vielleicht bist du da auch nicht richtig angepasst. Vielleicht hängst du da auch noch der Evolution hinterher. Naja, ich meine ja gar nicht, ich meine auch gar nicht, dass es das Ziel eines Lemuren, der Spezies sein muss oder der Natur sein muss, die durchzuballern als die nächste krasse Spezies. Aber es ist doch so, dass intelligente Tiere,
Specimen dieser Spezies, ja wahrscheinlich länger überleben. Das meine ich ja nur. Ich meine ja
gar nicht, dass die Natur jetzt den nächsten Menschen kreieren will oder so, das Guided
Evolution, das gibt es ja nicht. Aber warum? Weil intelligentere Tiere, müssen wir doch behaupten, verstecken sie wahrscheinlich besser, können besser Gefahren antizipieren, finden besser Blüten, Stau. Die Frage ist, was ist intelligent? Du setzt jetzt deine menschliche Intelligenz auf andere Tiere an. Der Tintenfisch ist ja für seine Verhältnisse maximal intelligent, für das, was er braucht. Der muss ja nicht das verstehen, was er versteht. Der ist auch schon weit vor allem, also eigentlich ist ja die Überspezies Homo recht unerfolgreich, weil ja nur eine einzige Spezies Homo sapiens es überhaupt durchgeschafft hat. Wohingegen es gibt hundert Tiger, es gibt hundert Affen, es gibt hundert Nacktschnecken, aber von Homo gibt es nur einen einzigen, weil da gab es ja auch andere und die sind ja alle ausgestorben. Ich verstehe auch genau, was du sagst. Also es ist eigentlich ja nur noch eine Frage der Zeit, bis die letzte Homo-Variante auch noch ausstirbt und dann war es das. Ich verstehe auch alles, was du sagst und ich sehe das auch alles eigentlich genauso und das ist auch gar nicht so. Meine Frage ist glaube ich einfach nur, warum werden nicht alle Lebewesen die ganze Zeit intelligenter? Warum sind die Menschen die einzigen, die diesen Schritt so geschafft haben? Ja, es ist ja auch kein nötiger Schritt. Es ist halt die Frage, ob es nicht auch Nachteile von Intelligenz gibt, dass Intelligenz auch ein Faktor sein kann, wo du aussortiert wirst. Wenn du zu intelligent bist und dir zu viele Gedanken machst, wie jage ich das jetzt oder so, dann bist du auch zu schlecht, dann bist du zu verkopft. Es kann auch sein, dass das in der Natur manchmal negativ ist. Nur für die Menschen war es halt leider ein Vorteil.
Das wäre diese verkopfte Spezies. Da hinten war das. Wissen Sie, diesen Trottel da hinten? Diesen grossen blauen Menschen?
Ja, Gott, jetzt denkt er danach. Da steht er, macht nichts.
Ja, aber wenn ich, nee. Aber jetzt, nee, lass. Du bist zu verkopft. Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß es ja, aber also, nee, ich denke ja nur nach, weil ich überlege gerade, ob ich nicht, weil ich habe jetzt hier eine Höhle, aber die andere ist halt weiter weg. Nimm den Speer und baller die Antilope weg. Ja, aus deiner Perspektive sieht das jetzt so leicht aus, aber das Problem ist ja, dass die so weit weg ist von der Höhle.
Und wenn ich jetzt wieder zurück...
Hier steht deine Intelligenz im Wege.
Nein, du verstehst nicht, was ich... Also, verstehst du, guck mal hier.
Erdbeben!
Hört auf, hört auf, hört auf!
Und die verkaufte Spezies ist weg.
Ja, warum sind eigentlich alle anderen Homo-Spezies ausgestorben?
Weil wir die...
Nein, wir haben nicht die... Also wir, die Neandertaler nicht. Du! Ich habe wirklich die Rumo-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi-Sabi anderen Homo-Spezies ausgestorben? Weil wir die ... Nein, wir haben nicht die ... Also wir, die Neandertaler nicht. Du! Ich? Du auch! Haben wirklich die Homo-Sapiens die Neandertaler ausgerottet? Nein. Nee, es gab ja auch Kreuzungen und sowas. Es gab ja, untereinander ist ja viel Schindluder betrieben worden. Aber, soweit ich weiß, gab es dann einfach Tote. Wie viele Homo gab es denn eigentlich? Homo sapiens, Homo sapiens sapiens, Homo erectus, Homo anatalensis, Homo economicus. Ne, da habe ich mich jetzt... Ach ja, da gibt es schon einige Arten. Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn, elf, zwölf, dreizehn, vierzehn. Aber sind das nicht teilweise Weiterentwicklungen voneinander? Ist eine Gattung der Menschenaffen. Hominidal. Ach, es gibt noch mal Menschenaffen obendrüber. Es gab schon einige, vierzehn Stück oder so, und wir haben alle rausgeballert. Wir haben schön alle, der Schwächste fliegt, ein nach dem anderen rausgeballert. Wie so ein Battle Royale, wo die Karte immer kleiner wird. Was für eine harte Liste, da ist immer so ein Kreuz für ausgestorben und alle sind ausgestorben, außer Homo sapiens. Das gibt es ja überhaupt nicht. Ah, guck mal, da ist es. Guck mal, vor allem wenn du auf den Wikipedia-Artikel von Homo Sabiens gehst, dann gibt es ja ein Bild immer.
Das heißt, man musste sich überlegen, welches Bild nehmen wir zu dem Wikipedia-Artikel Mensch.
Welcher ist der menschlichste Mensch?
Und der menschlichste Mensch ist Karl von Linné?
Der ist einfach so der Proto-Mensch. So, du bist es. Du bist es geworden.
Wie ist es Karl von Linné geworden?
Wahrscheinlich hat er die Menschen entdeckt oder so. Und dann ist ein Säugling, zehn Jahre alt, auch noch das geworden. Och Gott, ey, das ist... Aber jetzt würde ich gerne Dichter hochladen. Das ist nett von dir, danke Stefan. Und dann ist er ein nackter Mann und eine nackte Frau auch noch. Stefan, du darfst nicht so tief runterscrollen, Mensch. Jetzt bist du hier wieder ganz verwirrt im Rest der Folge.
Was machen die? Guck da nicht hin, Stefan. Aber das Selbstbewusstsein hätte ich gerne, mich nackt ablichten zu lassen für den Wikipedia-Eintrag von Homo Sapiens. Ja, schon, ne? Aber gibt's da, also ist das ein Casting oder schreiben die Modelagenturen an, weil die wollen ja keine Models haben, sondern normale Leute, sagen wir mal.
Also am liebsten Karl von Linné, aber jetzt ist... Also, Entschuldigung, das tut mir wirklich, Seither von Linné ist leider ausgebucht für die Woche.
Der ist noch auf dem Kindergeburtstag unterwegs und dann die Obieröffnung in Nordrhein-Westfalen. Sie wissen, das ist gerade die Saison. Der hat leider keine Zeit, sich ablichten zu lassen. Schauen Sie mal. Bei einem schwedischen Naturforscher, der mit der binären Nomenklatur die Grundlagen der modernen botanischen zoologischen Taxonomie schuf. Und da hat man gesagt, der ist so Mensch, der ist so menschlich. Das ist so menschlich, Dinge einzuordnen in zwei verschiedene Systeme, da menschelt es wirklich. Ja, will man ja auch nicht. Da fühlen wir uns auch wohl, da sagen wir, ja, nee, Dinge einzuordnen in die oder die Art, binäre Systeme, das ist der Mensch doch. Zwei Beine, zwei Arme, wir lieben es. Herr Linne, das ist so relatable. Ich will nicht sagen, ich könnte das auch. Ja, aber, ne? Erstmal, Sie sind für mich der Prototyp, es ist fast eine Beleidigung auch da zu sein, oder? Man ist so ein generic Wissenschaftler-Guy. Ja, das stimmt. Gestorben in Uppsala. Bei einem traischen Unfall in Uppsala gestorben. Es war von seinem Segway gefallen. In Hoppala geboren. Das ist menschlich, das ist einfach menschlich. Tollpatschigkeit gehört auch zu Menschen dazu. Das stimmt, ja, ja. Ja, aber es ist, ja, es geht mir nicht ganz aus dem Kopf, und ich finde die Antworten so einigermaßen unbefriedigend. Tut mir leid, dass ich dich immer wieder und wieder enttäuschen muss. Du enttäuschst mich. Du hast auch sehr gute Punkte gehabt, das stimmt schon alles. Aber du hast auch schon recht, man beträgt dann einfach die eigene Definition von Intelligenz auf Kolibris. Vor allem, wie schaffen wir es denn jetzt eigentlich wieder, mehr Artenvielfalt zu schaffen? Weil erst waren es 14, jetzt ist es nur noch eins. Wie geht es denn jetzt weiter? Also kommen wir jetzt irgendwann wieder auf zwei Homo oder ist jetzt Schluss? Nee, Schluss. Ich glaube, man müsste die nur lange genug isolieren. Das ist so ein Ding, wenn so, weil da gab es mal so diese Insel und da gab es dann Vögel, die haben oben im Norden angefangen und die eine Vogelart hat sich die eine Uferseite entlang entwickelt und die andere die andere. Und als die sich unten im Süden der Insel wieder getroffen haben, konnten die sich nicht mehr miteinander fortpflanzen. Ach, das glaube ich nicht. Weil die sich evolutionär so weit voneinander entfernt hatten, dass obwohl die als gleiche Vogelart gestartet haben, sich unten nicht mehr fortpflanzen konnten. Und das war eine Möglichkeit. Was habt ihr da gemacht? Wir treffen uns auf der, hey, wir treffen uns auf der anderen Seite. Ja, klar, klar, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy. Zwölftausend Jahre später. Hey, Rudi, na, what the hell, wo habt ihr diesen Hautkamm her? Ist das eine Bärennase? Hä? Ist das eine Bärennase? Ja, natürlich, wir sehen alle so aus. Warum? Hä, was sind das für längliche Organe an den Seiten? Ich weiß nicht, damit riech, fühlen, schmecken wir. Und wir können auch wahnsinnig gut fliegen. Fliegen? Ja. Das haben wir vor 100 Jahren verlernt. Wir können fliegen. Also hast du heute Abend noch was vor? Nö, ich würde mich gern mit dir. Okay, nee, weil ich hatte Zeit. Am nächsten Morgen. Es ist nicht kompatibel. Ich bin sonst gut darin. Ich kann dir das nicht erklären, das tut mir echt leid. Ich bin so gut darin sonst. Ich bin genauso überrascht wie du. Kannst du meine Ex-Freundin fragen? Ich bin nicht so schlecht. Aber es war nicht kompatibel. Du warst jetzt auch nervös, wir haben uns lange nicht gesehen. Hey, ist alles in Ordnung? Nee, ich sag nur, ich hab das Gefühl, es ist nicht mein Fehler, sondern es ist einfach so ein anatomisches Problem. Da ist auch viel Stress im Spiel und lass uns einfach das nochmal locker angehen. Vielleicht ging es auch einfach zu schnell. Lass uns einfach nochmal ein Eis trinken oder ein paar Würmer genießen oder so und dann lass uns locker angehen. Okay, alles klar. Okay, okay, okay, okay, alles klar. Am nächsten Morgen, ich habe dir gesagt, es lag nicht daran, dass ich nicht gestürzt habe. Vielleicht waren wir zu über. Das geht jahrelang so. Es finde ich sehr lustig. Aber ich glaube, so könnte man noch mal Artenvielfalt schaffen. Man müsste halt nur Planeten B finden. Man müsste halt nur verschiedene Gruppen Menschen lange genug voneinander trennen, also ich rede so von tausenden Jahren, und dann hätte man wahrscheinlich wieder verschiedene Unterarten, die sich nicht mehr fortpflanzen können untereinander. Das Leben ist schon ziemlich langweilig, wenn man nicht gerade zweitausend Jahre alt werden kann, ne? Aber ehrlich gesagt, weil dann kann man... Und wird es nicht dadurch erst langweilig, wenn du so zu alt wirst? Ne, dann checkt man die grossen Zusammenhänge. Ja, aber die hast du doch schon nach 30 Jahren verstanden, oder? Wir checken ja nicht. So schwierig ist es jetzt nicht. Aber solch für so ein Experiment wäre ich doch gerne 2000 Jahre alt. Was willst du denn noch verstehen nach 2000 Jahren? Nach 50 Jahren hast du alles verstanden, alles mal gesehen. Nein, nein, du hast alles verstanden in deinem kleinen Minitunnelblick deiner Lebenszeit, wo die Menschheit ja, ist alles ziemlich geprimed in deinem Kopf, weil du alles, was du gelernt hast, aus diesem Ausschnitt Menschheit hast. Ich glaube, nach 200 Jahren hast du alles gesehen. Dann gehst du in eine andere Kultur und merkst, im Grunde sind die ähnlich wie wir, gut leicht anderes Fest, leicht andere Musik oder so. Also cool, interessant, aber hat man dann halt auch gesehen. So, ja, die haben halt die Köpfe vergraben, wir stellen so einen Baum auf, aber die Idee ist ähnlich. Die haben halt so einen Drachenmonster, wir haben halt irgendwie so einen Monster aus dem Wald. Super. Ja, aber für das Experiment, dass man zwar eine B-Erde, Bärde aufstellt und da die Menschheit sich weiterentwickeln lässt, dann kommt man irgendwann nochmal zusammen. Ja, das stimmt, das ist doch, ich denke jetzt über Science Fiction nach, so die erste Kolonie auf dem Mars oder so. Und dann leben die da erstmal eine Weile und dann kommen die zurück und dann merkt man, die müssen, man muss sich ja verändern auf dem Mars, du passt dich ja der Umwelt an, oder? Also die sind wir jetzt so riskant. Man müssen sich ja verändern dann die Menschen. Ja, meiner Meinung nach auch. Also es ist ja die Frage, ob die dann in so einem Biotop leben, was halt dann die Erde nachbaut, dann wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber ansonsten kann es schon sein, dass die zurückkommen und dann halt einfach so Kiemen haben, die irgendeine Art von Gas rausfiltern, dass es auf dem Mars gibt. Und dann kommen die zurück und dann gibt es zwei verschiedene Menschenarten. Ja, das ist ja zwischenspannend. Und natürlich sind die auch viel, ähm, ja, jetzt will ich nichts Falsches sagen, aber es ist nicht weniger Gravitation auf dem Marsch, herrscht nicht weniger, ähm. Der ist ja kleiner, ne, aber näher an der Sonne. Nee, das ist egal. Aber wenn du kleiner bist, hast du weniger Anziehungskraft. Ja, genau. Und deswegen, ässer? Das weiß ich nicht. Ich würde sagen, einfach schwächer. Also müssen nicht so stark sein, weil sie nicht so viel gegen die Schwerkraft kämpfen müssen. Nehmen wir unseren dicken Beinen, die sich der Erde entgegenstellen, strammen. Das müssen die nicht. Oder wenn du auf dem Mond bist, bist du wahrscheinlich auch anders, wirst du auch ein bisschen weniger Muskelkraft. Ja. Warum waren die Dinosaurier früher so gross? Du hast die Lösung gesagt. Ich glaube, da gab es mehr Sauerstoff, glaube ich, oder so. Ich glaube, irgendwas war, dass es mehr Sauerstoff gab oder weniger, ich weiß auch nicht. Weil werden wir jetzt wieder kleiner, weil wir sind, ist gross, Evolutionsfolge, sorry, aber, weil wir sind. Weiß es doch nicht! Weil wir werden doch gerade grösser, das macht ja gar keinen Sinn mehr, warum bin ich denn so gross? Ja gut, aber das hat ja was mit der Ernährung zu tun. Über die Hecken des Nachbarn zu gucken. Als wir in Wien waren, waren wir im Museum und da gab es dann auch so laute Ritterrüstungen und so und die waren alle super klein. Wobei ich mir echt dachte, wow, in ein paar hundert Jahren, aber das ist halt ein, ich weiß nicht, ob das unter Evolution zählt oder ob man einfach besser ernährt wird von klein auf und deswegen besser wächst. Ich glaube nicht, dass das als Evolution zählt, aber die waren schon echt klein.
Ich glaube, ich hätte da so einen Ritter gekriegt.
Ja.
Also nichts gegen Barbarossa oder so oder Karl den Grossen, aber ich glaube in einem Eins-voreins, klar, der hat seine Leben lang Ausbildung am Schwert und so, klar, von den besten. Aber ich meine, ich habe Hederingen gesehen und Braveheart. Also die Basics kenne ich auch. Ich glaube, ich würde den lang machen. Naja. Also, nee, nee, nee, nee, sorry, Entschuldigung. Du würdest auch gegen Hund verlieren. Ich weiß, die arbeiten hier im Museum und sie kennen die genauen Daten nicht. Aber Entschuldigung, noch mal vor alle, ich würde einfach nur sagen, ich glaube, ich könnte den Karl den Grossen niederringen, Entschuldigung. Karl der Grosse, ne, heißt der. Ja, für die damalige Zeit. Für die damalige Zeit. Okay, dann setzen Sie sich mal diese VR-Brille auf, wir haben nämlich diese neue Experience hier vorbereitet. Alles klar, okay. Und sie heißt One V One, Karl der Grosse. Komm, gib mir auch gleich Napoleon, komm. Eins, zwei, zwei, fuck it. Geht's noch nicht? Komm, gib mir Napoleon und Genghis Khan. Hau die alle rein, du, mach die alle kaputt jetzt hier. Hä? Ich programmiere kurz. Kein Problem, ich zieh mir kurz meine Jacke aus. Wollen wir auch direkt noch Buffalo Bill dazu bringen? Buffalo Bill, komm, gib mir Mutter Teresa auch noch, fuck it. Häuptling Sitting Bull. Okay, also Sie kämpfen jetzt gegen Häuptling Sitting Bull. Okay. George Washington. Easy. Napoleon. Okay. Und Karl der Grosse. Kein Problem. In einem Alle gegen Alle. Free for All. Wie heißt nochmal dieser Leather? Ne, dieser Leiter. Ich habe mich mit Leather. Was heißtiter noch mal? Das ist ein Leiterkampf bei Wrestling, bei WWE. Weiß ich nicht mehr. Wie meinst du? Es gibt so ein Alle gegen Alle, man muss die Leiter hochsteigen und oben ist so ein Koffer, den man holen muss, so ein Cage-Match. Das will ich sehen. Du meinst Familienduell. Das ist Wrestling Napoleon eine reinhauen. Jetzt machen sie es nicht so kompliziert. Klappt das denn? Ja, Leiter-Match. Kann ich jetzt anfangen oder nicht? So, es geht gleich los. Sehen Sie sich schon? Jetzt können Sie die Brille aufsetzen. Sehen Sie Napoleon? Ich sehe Napoleon. Komm her, hast du ein Problem, haben wir ein Problem. Wenn Sie nach links gucken, sehen Sie. Haben wir ein Problem. Hier, die linke, Liberté, die rechte, Fraternité, sonst kommen wir her. In eine Fresse-Tee. Dann links liest du Häuptling Sitting Bull. Okay, alles klar. Der soll aufstehen. Der bereitet sich auf den Kampf vor. Aber das ist doch, wenn der sitzt, ist das doch albern. Kleiner Tipp, ich würde ihm sofort die Waffe entnehmen, sonst haben sie keine Chance. Dann, leider links, sehen sie George Washington. Okay, winzig klein, winzig klein, gibt mir nicht mal zur Hüfte, den trete ich ja direkt weg. Liest ein Buch auch, wie wir wissen, ob Sie das gesehen haben. Ja, und er hat Holzzähne, der ist überhaupt keine Gefahr. So, und Buffalo Bill. Okay. Ja gut, das ist vielleicht ein kleines Problem. Ja, und alles klar, dann halt du dich erst mal zurück, Bill, Billy. Die Idee ist quasi, dass ihr euch alle bekriegt, jeder gegen jeden. Okay, ich hau dir alle gleich um. Und dann muss man sich eine Leiter holen und aufstellen, weil oben siehst du, unter der Decke hängt ein Koffer, ein Geldkoffer. Okay, das mache ich, wenn ich die alle umgehauen habe, dann mache ich das in Ruhe. Ja, das ist mir egal mit dem Koffer. Ja, okay. Wir dachten nur, es wäre ein Ziel zu haben. Ich verstehe das, aber das ist mir jetzt auch egal. Okay, alles klar. Und Ladies and Gentlemen! Okay, es geht los in drei, zwei, eins, Fight! Und wir sehen Herbert aus Schwerin, stürmt direkt vor und tritt George Washington erstmal direkt um, einfach schön weggetreten, liegt auf dem Boden, hält sich das Knie und währenddessen Buffalo Bill...
George Washington ist, glaube ich, knocked out.
George Washington ist aus, wir sehen drei, zwei, eins, ja, George Washington ist raus, Silling Bull sitzt immer noch, schaut sich das Ganze aus der Entfernung an, währenddessen Napoleon versucht sich zurückzuziehen, Buffalo Bill geht aber direkt auf ihn los, zieht ihn und einmal sagt, schön von hinten, tritt ihn einmal in den Rücken. Nein, nein. Da geht er zu Boden, währenddessen Horst aus Schwerin kommt von der Seite, versucht Buffalo Boney, der Beine wegzuziehen, schafft er das, oh, da schafft er es nicht ganz, tritt leider gegen den Rand, tritt gegen den Käfig, jetzt hat er selber Probleme, Buffalo Bill kommt nochmal gegen Sitting Bull von hinten an, trete ihn gegen den Hinterkopf, was ist da los? Das ist ja das Allerbeste. Warum gibt's das nicht? Fight your heroes. Ja. Fight Nikolai Tesla. Never fight your heroes. Das ist ja mega geil. Ja, warum nicht? Warum nicht, ne? Es gab ja dieses Celebrity Deathmatch von MTV, aber da konnte man halt selber nicht mitmachen, weil ich hatte immer zu wenig Knete, ich habe immer versucht, zu Hause das nachzukneten, aber ich hatte nie genug. Ach so, ich dachte, du hast wenig Geld. Knete? Du siehst du wenig Knete? Bin ich jemand, bei dem du denkst, dass ich Knete zu Geld sag? Ich sag Moneten. Ich bin Monetentyp, Steffen, das weißt du aber auch ganz genau. Ja, ich hatte ein bisschen zu wenig Knete und das ist dann weitergegangen, das bin ich um Knete, das hat mich da gerade schon sehr irritiert. Ich hatte einfach zu wenig Knete. Ich bin ein Moneten- oder Mäuse-Typ, bei mir geht es eher in die Richtung M. Okay, macht Sinn, Money. Wie viele Mäuse hast du dabei gerade? Stutz. Oh, Stutz habe ich irgendwie gehört. Doch, 50 Stutz. Das gibt viele gute Wörter. Kröten? Kröten sind auch, oh, Kröten ist glaube ich das Beste. Kröten. Wo sind die Kröten? Zaster. Du bist ein guter Sidekick, der immer so hehehehehehe. der immer daneben steht und so, ganz kleines, aber nicht immer hypt.
Ja.
Denn er nach Hause geht zu seiner Frau und sagt, er hat mich heute gar nicht beachtet.
Er hat nichts gesagt.
Dann musst du auch wirklich... Aber willst du nicht mal mit ihm reden, weil du meinst, er hat jetzt wieder nicht dir was abgegeben von dem Geld, das er geklaut hat und er hat dich wieder kleiner Ad genannt? Nein, du weißt ja, wie es ist. Also wenn es gut läuft, dann ist es ein tolles Gefühl und dann fühlt man sich auch anerkannt, wenn er dann mal sagt, gut gemacht oder sowas. Klein, lang Zahn. Aber das sagt dann ja auch manchmal nicht so. Und dann ist es natürlich erstmal schwierig. Aber hast du mal mit ihm drüber gesprochen? Meinst du, der weiss überhaupt, weil wie gesagt, es gibt ja unterschiedliche Arten, die Menschen ihre Liebe zeigen. Manche durch Geschenke, manche durch Komplimente. Und ich glaube, wenn er weiss einfach, dass dir das wichtig ist, dass du auch hier und da mal ein Kompliment bekommst, dann kann er damit ganz anders umgehen. Aber Schatz, wenn man so ein toller Bösewicht ist, das wird man nicht einfach so, da muss man schon so ein bisschen hart sein. Aber warum ist er denn so geworden, wie er ist? Warum ist er denn ganz oben? Ja, auch wegen dir. Und ich glaube, das ist ihm manchmal nicht klar. Und ich glaube, wenn er wüsste, wie er dich glücklich machen kann, wenn du ihm einfach sagst, hey, ich brauche einfach mal ein nettes Wort am Feierabend.
Ich glaube, dann kann er auch da besser drauf eingehen, weil er weiss glaube ich gar nicht,
dass du hier jeden Abend nach Hause kommst und unglücklich bist.
Ja, Schatz, du hast recht. Ich werde es dir morgen sagen.
Dann red doch morgen nochmal mit ihm, okay?
Okay.
Wollen wir noch eine Runde Scrabble spielen?
Ja.
Gern.
Das Wort lege ich hier gern immer.
Messer?
Ja.
Du bringst deinen Job immer noch nach Hause, Schatz.
Ich liebe dich ganz toll über alles.
Ich finde, du hast auch deine Momente.
Am nächsten Morgen bei der Arbeit.
So, Jungs, ihr wisst, was wir heute vorhaben. Zwei Wagen. Boss, Boss, Boss. Hä, was denn? Kleiner Langzahn-Eddie. Jetzt, wo wir die Feinde in die Flucht geschlagen haben ... Ja, das gehört jetzt uns!
Wollte ich Ihnen mal was sagen.
Mit Menge VHS-Rekorder. Du kriegst ein.
Hehehehe.
Die gehören uns, die gehören uns.
Sie sind so herrlich scheusslich, sind sie.
Also, pack die Lieferung mal zusammen und pack alles ins Lager.
Alles klar. Morgen die gleiche Zeit.
Es hilft vielleicht, wenn Sie mir ab und zu sagen,
dass ich auch ein wichtiger Bestandteil bin der Gruppe. Was? Wie meinst du? Naja, die sind auch da, wo sie sind, wegen mir. Na, was willst du denn sagen? Ich bin der Boss, okay? Ja, klar, Boss, klar, Boss, Boss, Boss. Du kriegst den Teil, den ich für dich bereitlege. Aber ich hab dir so oft geholfen, euch, ich hab euch so oft geholfen, sie wären nicht da, meine Frau hat auch gesagt, wenn, sie wären nicht da, wo sie sind ohne mich, und immer sagen sie Add zu mir, ich hab gesagt Langzahn, Langzahn. Ich bin mehr als so ein kleiner Sidekick. Ich muss sagen, es wäre nicht dasselbe ohne dich. Immer wenn wir den anderen Banden gegenüberstehen, ja, ich brauche das mittlerweile. Diese eine Woche, die du Urlaub genommen hast. Teneriffa. Ja, da muss ich sagen, da hast du mir echt gefehlt. Das war super. Die Anlage kann ich auch empfehlen. Das war so ein Rio-Hotel. Und klar, all inclusive immer Frage, Essen und so. Aber es war dafür echt gut und so und auch Animation nicht so aufdringlich und so, wenn man Wasserball oder Beachvolleyball spielen will. Aber was ich sagen will, in der Zeit hast du mir echt gefehlt. Und das war einfach nicht das Gleiche. Deswegen, du bist echt ein wichtiger Teil der Truppe und du bist mir echt ans Herz gewachsen. Und ich finde dich wirklich wichtig. Und als du heute diesem Typen das Messer direkt in die Rippen gerammt hast, das war einfach toll. Das macht keiner so wie du. Es tut halt gut, das zu hörenst. Es tut gut, dass du hörst. Komm her, langsam. Und deswegen müsst ihr Leuten ab und zu mal sagen, dass sie ein wichtiger Bestandteil eurer Bösewicht-Gruppe sind. Genau. Das ist Learning. Geld alleine reicht manchmal nicht aus. Viele Leute arbeiten nicht für Geld, sondern auch für Anerkennung. Alle, ich würde sagen alle. Weil Geld ist ja auch für Anerkennung. Aber auch für Zaster. Aber auch für Kröten, aber natürlich, auch Geld hat man ja dann auch wiederum viel für Anerkennung. Da geht es dann auch irgendwann darum, sich Statussymbole von zu kaufen und so. Haben wir gerade große Lösungen für Probleme? Deswegen sage ich, wir haben es geschafft, was willst du denn noch 200 Jahre lang machen, wenn du jetzt unendlich lange leben kannst? Wir haben es ja schon, guck mal, du bist Anfang 20 und hast es schon verstanden. Ja, ich bin durch. Und jetzt, du bist durch. Rest ist Bonus. Das ist so, wenn du ein Videospiel durchgespielt hast und dann nochmal so durch die Gegend läufst und so, und dann findest du hier und da noch einen Rubin und so. Aber eigentlich hast du es doch geschafft. Ich denke auch manchmal so, ja, ich bin durch. Also alles, was ich jetzt noch lerne, ist Bonus. Ich habe alles einigermaßen zu einer, also nicht verstanden, das will ich mich nicht anmassen, aber so verstanden, dass ich damit zufrieden bin. Ich habe alles in einer Tiefe durchdrungen, mit der ich zufrieden bin. Ich bin sehr leicht zufrieden zu stellen, offensichtlich. Aber alles, was ich jetzt noch dazu, was ich so lerne, ist alles noch ein Bonus. Was wäre für dich so eine optimale Lebenszeit? Dann reicht der 50 Jahre auch. Ja, das reicht dann auch irgendwann. Reicht dann irgendwann und dann wirklich so auf der Bühne sterben, einfach so. Oh Gott, ey. In so einem grossen, nicht so einem grossen Moment, sondern einfach so kurz abrutschen und dann irgendwie dumm landen und dann wirklich mal dein Gesicht auch sehen, wie du dann sagst, oh, shit, ey.
Shit.
Ja, wenn du auf der Bühne stirbst, da habe ich ja grosse Angst vor, weil ich das wahrscheinlich live erlebe aus einer ersten Reihe Platz.
Und du dann einfach noch 30 Minuten füllen musst bei der Live-Show. Ja, genau, weil es einfach weitergeht dann. Weil es einfach weitergeht. Ich würde ja nicht weitermachen, Florenton. Oh, das ist nett. Das ist nett? Das ist nett. Du würdest dann direkt zum Merch dann gehen und sagen, Leute. Ich würde dann, klar, also Merch wird noch verkauft nach der Show. Na klar. Und ich würde noch Fotos machen. Aber ich würde jetzt nicht die Show weitermachen, weil das ist respektlos. So. Hör mal Leute, was ist denn hier los? Unser Büro dreht durch. Wir versuchen hier zu arbeiten gerade, hört man das? Wie unsere wilden, Leute, wie unsere wilden Kollegen hier vorbeikommen, das ist aber auch einfach eine junge Firma, muss man sagen. Ja, hier ist ein Startup-Führer. Das ist hier baule, das Leben, hier Startup überall, hier wird gerade die nächste Bumble-Tinder-App entwickelt, der nächste Coin, die nächste Kryptowährung, die hier entsteht. Oh, aber ich weiß nicht, ob du gesehen hast, in der Küche stehen schon so passiv-aggressive Post-its. Ah, yes! Ja, ich habe dir die Frage gestellt, wie lange das dauert und ich habe eigentlich gedacht, so nach drei Wochen. Es sind jetzt mehrere Monate und jetzt sind die ersten wirklich bösen Post-its. Ja. So, bitte unbedingt dieriges Geschirr direkt in die Spülmaschine räumen.
Und wenn die Spülmaschine voll ist,
dann erstmal ausräumen.
Spülmaschine, ey.
Warum hat sich denn da auch nichts weiterentwickelt?
Doch, ist schon super.
Aber einfach so vom Gedanken,
vom System, irgendwie ist das immer ein Problem.
Der Mensch ist das Problem,
der dann, das habe ich schon oft gesehen,
wie der Bödel hier nebenan, dann immer seine Sachen einfach dahin legt. In die Spüle, die dreckigen Sachen. Ja. Da muss man sich mal die Zeit nehmen, das nochmal einzuräumen. Da muss es doch ein besseres System geben oder so, dass man dann direkt in den Schränken dann da irgendwie, also dass du vielleicht sozusagen, dass nicht nur ein Platz die Spülmaschine ist, sondern dass die Schränke selber die Spülmaschinen sind, hör mich an. Also wenn du mit deinem Essen fertig bist, stellst du den dreckigen Teller einfach zu den sauberen dazu und der Schrank selber ist die Spülmaschine, wo halt dann immer nachts oder so Wasser kommt und gespült wird und läuft dann alles ab, sodass es direkt da schon sauber ist und dann auch getrocknet wird. Ja, es hat null energieeffizient, wenn du die ganze Zeit saubere Teile nochmal sauber machen musst. Ja, warum? Und du hast die ganze Zeit in der Spülmaschine läuft. Du machst doch auch die Spülmaschine jedes Mal sauber, ohne dass die dreckig ist. Die Maschine selbst. Und die ganzen Stangen, die da drin sind und so, die sind ja auch nicht dreckig. Ja, aber du machst ja nicht nur dreckige Sachen plötzlich. Es kostet doch nicht mehr Energie, wenn du zusätzlich zu den schmutzigen auch noch sauberer fährst. Naja, natürlich, weil viel häufiger macht die ja sauber gerade. Viel häufiger macht die ja gerade sauber dann in deinem Szenario. Wenn du, erst mal, hast du gerade aus einer Spielmaschine vier Spielmaschinen gemacht, aus vier Schränken, die jeden Abend läuft, die jeden Abend läuft, alle vier. Du räumst dreckige Sachen zu den sauberen, dadurch muss ja jede dann irgendwie einmal laufen nachts. Das heißt, es ist jetzt schon weniger energieeffizient. Aber ja, also ich verstehe auch nicht. Also zum Beispiel, jetzt mal wirklich langfristig gedacht, Science Fiction, ich bin da gerade noch drin, kann man nicht so eine Ultragravitationsbox haben oder so, dass du dann so da den Teller reinlegst und dann wird die Schwerkraft so stark erhöht, dass alles, was nicht Teller ist, nach unten gezogen wird, sodass der ganze Schmutz einfach weggezogen wird. Also Wasser ist überhaupt nicht mehr im Spiel, sondern, du könntest ja zum Beispiel sagen, du hast eine Maschine, die kann Gravitation steuern und auch Gegenstände ausnehmen, also dass sozusagen der Teller nicht betroffen wird, sondern alles andere wird mit super hoher Schwerkraft dann weggesaugt und dann kannst du den Teller sofort rausnehmen. Ich habe eine andere Idee, Waschstrasse, eine kleine Waschstrasse. Stellt man sich halt sehr lang vor, kann man sich aber so auf eine Fusszeile, also unten, weißt du, wo unten, vorstellen, legt man an Boden unten, dann versteckt man es so ein bisschen im Raum, und dann kann man aber einen Teller reinlegen, der fährt einmal durch, und hinten kommt der sauber wieder raus. Und da stapelt es sich dann. Und dann kommen so fiese Post-its, saubere Sachen aus der Waschstrasse, bitte nicht Tränkeräumen. Ja. Und da kannst du alles reinschieben, und es braucht dann so, alles braucht so 1,30 und ist dann fertig. Ich bin eher bei der Gravitationskammer, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Also Bosch, falls du zuhörst. Dann forsch doch du an der Gravitationskammer. Dann machen wir das so, Bosch, falls du zuhörst, weil ich glaube, Wasser ist langfristig nicht die richtige Richtung. Sondern du brauchst irgendwas, was sozusagen Schmutz von Nichtschmutz trennt und das sofort wegsaugt, eliminiert. Oder einen Flammenwerfer oder so. Achso. Ich dachte, ich weiß, was Zeug war bei Fisch. Du nimmst halt irgendwie, du hast so eine Feuerkammer, die Kammer des Schreckens, und da stellst du irgendwie dein Geschirr rein. Und wie so eine Mikrowelle, machst du zu und dann und dann wird alles, was Schmutz ist, halt einfach verbrannt und vaporisiert. Und dann nimmst du das raus und die sind halt leicht warm und dann ist alles fertig. Und dann legst du deinen Puddinglöffel da rein und dann wird der ganze Pudding verbrannt, weg und übrig bleibt nur der komplett saubere Löffel. Andere Idee ist so ein Fisch, wie diese die Füsse sauber machen und von überflüssigem Hornhaut befreien. Einfach so ein Bassin und da legst du dann die Sachen rein und die stürzen sich da drauf und machen den komplett sauber. Das ist gut, ja. Und dann machst du das raus. Ich finde, wir sollten viel mehr Tiere für uns arbeiten lassen. Hunde haben wir schon gut geknackt, die machen schon gute Arbeit für uns auf jeden Fall. Ja. Aber so viele, vor allem wie gesagt aus dem Tierreich, Meeresfrüchte, wie ich finde, sehr abwertend genannt werden. Ja, genau, exakt abwertend. Also dieses Essen aus dem Meeren wird Meeresfrüchte genannt. Dass du die Tiere auch, wenn die uns helfen sollen, Meeresfrüchte nennst. Meeresfrüchtchen, die auch gehören. Meeresbonbons. Einfach so abwerten, einfach direkt. Wer ist hier der Chef nochmal? Ach ja, die Spezies, die die alle aufisst. Ja, richtig, jetzt haben wir es nochmal. Jetzt haben wir es nochmal genau gehört. Meeresfrüchte. Das stimmt, das ist mir auch so ein merkwürdiges Wort. Das ist mir auch so ein negativ aufgefallen. Das sind Krebse. Reine Dominanz. Meeresfrüchte. Reine Dominanz. Auch dass man das alles so salatartig in einen Teller wirft.
Was ist das, Muschelkrab?
Scheißegal.
Lecker, lecker, lecker, alles rein.
Haust mir auf die Pizza drauf.
Egal, was das für Sachen sind.
Pizza, Meeresfrüchte.
Drauf da, njam, njam, njam, frutti, rein da.
Völlig egal.
Hä? Warum sind nicht Algen eure Meeresfrüchte?
Oder so Korallen? Warum wir? Wir sind Krebstziere. Warum gibt es eigentlich kein Unterwasserobst? Also warum gibt es nicht so etwas wie einen schönen Kürbis oder eine Melone unter Wasser? Weil Überwasser ist das Prinzip eher tausende Jahre alt. Vogel frisst die Frucht, dadurch verbreitet sich dann der Samen irgendwo anders hin, weil der Vogel dann nach Hause fliegt und da wächst der neue Baum. Super System. Warum ist es unter Wasser kein Thema? Also warum sagt man nicht, man hat hier so ein geiles Früchtchen, so ein süßes kleines Unterwasserkirsche und dann kommt so ein Fisch, frisst die auf, trägt den Kern woanders hin? Wegen der Strömung? Weil man wegen der Strömung eh schon immer in in Bewegung ist oder was? Das stimmt schon, ich finde auch die Pflanzen unter Wasser sind ja gar nicht so, also wenn man jetzt vom Meer ausgeht, gibt es da viele Pflanzenfresser? Das glaube ich nämlich auch fast gar nicht so sehr. Ich glaube also, wenn man so das ganz eng vergleicht. Plankton wird ja viel gefressen, das wird ja immer gern genommen. Klar, Plankton wird immer gern genommen. Plankton ist ja auch ein Kleinstlebewesen. Aber es stimmt, wer frisst Algen sowas, ne? Also es gibt nicht jetzt so eine Meereskuh, die rumläuft und einfach den ganzen Tag. Doch, doch, doch, doch. So literally die Seekuh. Aber die frisst doch keine Algen, die nascht doch nicht Algen. Doch, die ballert auch unten Seegras weg und so. Und es gibt ja auch Wälse, die bei mir die Algen aus dem Aquarium damals gefressen haben. Dann gibt es die Fische, die die Wälse gefressen haben. Es gibt immer einen noch größeren Fisch. Ja, das stimmt schon, aber du hast recht, irgendwie habe ich auch das Gefühl, dass da nicht so viel … Ja, das ist mehr Fleisch-Action, also Meeresfrucht-Action. Man isst, ja, weiß ich nicht, aber vielleicht auch einfach komplett falsche Wahrnehmung, weil die Tiere, für die man sich da unter Wasser interessiert, sind so gross, dass sie dann auch andere Tiere essen. Es ist so wahnsinnig viel in der Natur. Ich war letztens auch im Wald unterwegs und ich dachte mir, man denkt ja immer so, oh, raus aus der Stadt, wo so viel Trubel ist und los und endlich mal ein Wald, wo Ruhe ist. Auch Trubel. Nein, der Wald ist auch eine Stadt.
Wenn man sich da wirklich mal auf dem Boden hinsetzt und guckt,
da sind ja hunderte Leute unterwegs auf dem Weg zur Arbeit,
kommen zu spät, klettern hoch, haben sich verlaufen, hier und da.
Rudi, Rudi, wo sind bis jetzt? Na hier.
So, und dann müssen die sich finden und hin und her und Riesending. Und da ist einfach ein riesiges Wimpen, nur weil die halt kleiner sind. Und dann habe ich so einen Borkenkäfer beobachtet, der ist auf so einen Stein geklettert. Und dann ist er vom Stein so ganz seitlich, wo ich dachte, pass auf Kollege, pass auf Kollege, das ist jetzt ein ziemliches Gefälle, der hing da so richtig dran. Und ist er einfach so runtergestürzt und ist dann einfach direkt auf wirklich so locker einen Meter gefallen, was ja für einen Käfer enorme Distanz ist, einfach so auf dem Rücken und dann lag der einfach da. Und ich dachte mir, ist der jetzt einfach in seinen Tod gestürzt? Liegt der jetzt da? Und ich dachte mir, das kann nicht sein. Und er lag wirklich auf seinem Rücken, lag der Käfer einfach da und ich dachte mir, das kann nicht sein, dass ich gerade beobachtet habe, wie der einfach von diesem grossen Steinbrocken in seinen Tod gestürzt ist. Da habe ich wirklich minutenlang gewartet. Und es hat so ein paar Minuten gedauert. Und dann hat er wieder angefangen zu zappeln, hat sich umgedreht und ist weggelaufen. Aber der hat erstmal so einen kurzen Schock. Oh Gott. Schockmoment. Oh Gott, warte, trockle du. Ja genau. Lang wirklich erstmal da. Mit Seitenstechen da. Oh, der leckt mich, der leckt mich am Arsch. Hei, hei, hei, hei. Na, das ist mal ein Montag. Hei, der da, das hat mich jetzt aber, den habe ich nicht kommen sehen. Ich dachte, ich kann mich da festhalten. Oh, weiter geht's. Alles gut, alles gut, komm, alles gut.
Eine kleine Ameisenkolonie geht vorbei.
Alles in Ordnung, danke, danke, danke, alles gut.
Dann dreht er sich um und dann geht's weiter.
Weg. Aber der musste einfach ein paar Minuten
erstmal einfach liegen.
Aber ich finde es sehr gut, dass du um dem
Großstadttrubel zu entfliehen in den Wald
gehst, wo du dann so furchtbare Sachen
sehen musst. Ja, genau, wo jemand abstürzt. Vor allem bei Tieren, der liegt dannhen, in den Wald gehst, wo du dann so furchtbare Sachen sehen musst.
Ja genau, wo jemand abstürzt.
Vor allem bei Tieren, der liegt dann da, da gibt es niemanden, der dem hilft.
Äh, naja, glaube ich nicht. Tiere helfen sich.
Ja?
Kenne ich aus Zoo-Videos.
Ja, stimmt, manchmal so Schildkröten, die eine liegt auf dem Rücken und dann kommt die andere und stösst den anderen.
Das stimmt, das gibt es schon.
Aber es holen auch manchmal andere Tiere aus Wasser und so raus. Die helfen sich. Tiere sind sehr nette Menschen. Wirklich. Ja, jetzt ausser du bist Fresskonkurrent oder Feind, dann glaube ich nicht. Wenn ein Vogel ankommt, der würde dem Käfer jetzt nicht helfen. Der würde dem direkt mit dem Schnabel von oben ins ungeschützten Bauch rammen. Mich würde ja so, also wirklich dieses, wenn Tiere reden können, mich würde ja so interessieren, wie Tiere sich untereinander sehen. Also, wir haben so einen Wald, das ist ja wie eine Riesen-WG, so wo die Borkenkäfer und die Ameisen und die Würmer, wie sehen die sich gegenseitig? Sagen die, boah, diese scheiß Ameisen, erängen die mir auf die Nerven. Oder sagen das, ah, meine Nachbarn, morgen, morgen. Also mögen die sich oder ignorieren die sich komplett? Können die in irgendeiner Weise kommunizieren? Oder sind es einfach wandelnde Blackboxes für die, die einfach Fragezeichen? Ich war jetzt auch im Naturkundemuseum und da war ein ausgestoffter Elch. Und der hatte so einen dusseligen Gesichtsaussicht. Da dachte ich ich mir, wenn das jetzt andere Elche sehen würden, würden die dann sich dann ärgern. Die sich kaputt lagen. Man müsste eigentlich mal Tiere in ein Tiermuseum führen. Ja, genau. Und gucken, was die machen. Also schauen die sich dann eher die eigene Spezies an oder gucken die auch andere an oder ist denen alles scheißegal? Ich glaube, die wissen erst mal nicht, was hier los ist. Ja, weil die nichts riechen dann wahrscheinlich, oder wenn das Tier
schon so lange tot ist. Ja, aber dann war das so ein,
vielleicht dachte ich, vielleicht ist das ein hässlicher Elch.
Und als die Elche
will man ja dann auch einen coolen Vertreter da haben.
Das stimmt, ja.
So ein Karl von Linné
des Elchen
wollen die ja dann im Wiener
Naturkundumis. Ja, den besten Elch wollen die auch
ausgestellt haben. Aber der war so ein bisschen dusselig, er hat so ein bisschen dusselig geguckt, Dennis. Und die anderen lachen sich kaputt. Dennis der Elch. Oh Gott, da guckst du einmal dumm und dann stellen die dich da jahrhundertelang ins Museum rein. Ja, und andere ärgern sich dann, dass das der Vertreter ist. Warum ist genau der Elch jetzt da im Museum? Bei Menschen würde man sich auch die Frage stellen, warum ist das jetzt gerade... Ja, und das muss man sich schon fragen, wie die das sehen würden und was sie für große Unterschiede in sich erkennen. Oder ob das alles nur über Pheromone, Gerüche und so ausgeht, das weiß ich nicht. Weil Menschen haben ja auch eine klare Rangliste. So, eine Maus ist ja auch unter einem Hund. So, für einen Hund, den holt man aus dem Wasser raus und Hilfe und Operation und so.
Und da jetzt irgendwie so eine Milbe oder so, Flo, völlig egal.
Ist das bei Tieren auch so oder haben die, oder wie sehen Tiere auch Menschen?
Das wäre interessant. Also du kannst ja mal, wirft man ein kleines Tier ins Wasser und ein Hund, von dem man schon mal gesehen hat, der hilft anderen Tieren aus dem Wasser raus.
Gute Idee.
Und dann wirft man erstmal einen anderen kleinen Hund ins Wasser. Hups, und dann der Hund rettet den kleinen Hund. Aber man gibt ihm irgendwie Schwimmflügel, dass der nicht wirklich in Gefahr ist. Genau. Dann eine kleine Katze wirft man rein mit Schwimmflügeln. So, und dann guckt man, ob der Hund die kleine Katze rettet. Wahrscheinlich schon. Jetzt dann mal aus Spaß einen kleinen Fuchs. Mal gucken, was passiert. Ja, einfach mal schauen. Ja, mal gucken, was passiert. Und dann mal so ein Vogel rein oder so, mal so eine ganz andere Art von Tier. So ein Vogel und dann mal einfach aus Gag mal so ein Hummer rein. So ein Hummer. Denkt der Hund, uh, oder checkt der Hund, nee, der gehört da rein. Oder ist der Hund, also checkt der Hund, was für eine Art von Tier das ist.. Ist ein geiles Experiment. Und dann kannst du ja sehen, was hat der Hund für eine Rangliste. Genau. Auch wie lange er überlegt, solches Retten, eigenes. In wie viel Gefahr er sich selber begibt. Genau, nass werden, abwägen. Ja. Und dann musst du, genau, kannst du eine Rangliste, dieser speziellen Hundeart, sind das die beliebtesten Tiere. Ja, Biber, Dachs und so, solche Sachen holt ihr die raus. Ist eine richtig geile Idee. Macht das mal, schickt uns mal Videos davon, wir würden das gerne sehen und dann stellen wir die große Rangliste auf. Ja, ihr versteht schon, wie das gemeint ist für die Wissenschaft. Das macht mal, es ist ein Nachmittag. Ja, ihr versteht schon, wie es gemeint ist. Für manche Tiere ist es unangenehm, bei Katzen finde ich es gemein, die mögen echt kein Wasser. Aber so ein Dachs oder so, das ist doch cool, ist okay für den. Ja, das passt schon. Dachshund ist ja verwandt auch. Ist ja auch eine Kreuzung. Macht das mal und dann schickt uns die Ergebnisse, ansonsten wünschen wir euch weiterhin eine fantastische Woche. Wir wünschen euch das Beste, wir wünschen euch die beste Woche. Nur das Beste für euch diese ganze Woche. Haut rein, vielen, vielen Dank und bis zum nächsten Mal. Eine Sache noch, habt ihr vielleicht mitbekommen, wir haben noch nicht so viel darüber gesprochen in diesem Podcast, weil es ein anderes Projekt ist, wollen es euch trotzdem gerne mal vorstellen. Florentin und ich, wir machen und wir hoffen, dass es jetzt einigermaßen ein bisschen regelmäßiger klappen könnte, in der Zukunft in Köln Improv-Shows, Long-Form-Improv-Shows. Tietze und Will. Tietze und Will. Wir üben das gerade noch, das sind Probeshows, die sind komplett kostenlos. Ihr könnt euch bewerben auf Tickets, es gibt immer eine Ticketverlosung für die Shows, die kündigen wir immer an.
Folgt dafür einfach am besten unserem Instagram-Account Tietze und Will oder besucht die Website Tietze und Will.de.
Und dann sehen wir uns vielleicht, würde uns freuen, ansonsten macht's gut und wir heben ab, ciao!